pelé était présenté au public ainsi que
dix jeunes espoirs du cinéma français
avec leur parrain jean claude brialy
reportage pascal deschamps regardez les
bien ils se sont prêtés y reçoit roger
les photographes avec le sourire
mais pour une fois nastasia kinski
claude berri et les huit autres membres
du jury devront rester dans l'ombre
on a dit que la sélection 88 du festival
était austère ettore scola le président
lui attend de voir
je suis l'amstrad rencontrer des
chefs-d'oeuvre ce sale espoirs de tout
le cinéma car je suis sûr qu'avec
quelque chose le cinéma bas reprenne de
la toussaint sa force et sa place dans
la culture espoirs côté comédiens lucas
belvaux l'un des dix jeunes acteurs
français présenté hier soir pendant la
cérémonie d'ouverture ne s'y attendait
pas une chambre au carlton un smoking
comme dans les rêves mais on lui a tous
prêtés dans sa tenue de gala et avec les
chaussures qui était à lui lucas belvaux
à 26 ans et déjà cinq films derrière lui
vous l'avez peut-être vu dans le poulet
au vinaigre de claude chabrol mais être
espoir à cannes c'est parfois frustrant
c'est un peu ce statut d'espoir au mieux
les stars qui est un petit peu
indigo bizarre dire parce que on connaît
tout le monde en parlait à tout le monde
et en même temps personne gens nous
connaissent donc où l'on est un peu en
prix entre entre deux feux on est dans
les voitures officielles et jan
ceulemans qui attend ils nous voient
certains ne reconnaissent pas d'eau
c'est très très très curieux comme comme
sensation c'est de toute façon agréable
d'être là parce que parce que c'est le
plus grand festival du monde et être
invitée à le plus grand festival du
monde c'est très gratifiant mais c'est
curieux avides et puis loin de la foule
et des photographies lie à ses canaux à
qui je préférerais ne pas être là du
tout comme cet antiquaire que nous avons
surpris ce matin en train de fermer
boutique
pendant quinze jours kahn est vraiment
la ville du cinéma beaucoup
d'embouteillages est une ville un petit
peu asphyxié et moi mes clients ne
viennent plus alors j'ai d'autres choses
à faire ailleurs et je m'en réjouis